all right look you guys don't want to
talk about stuff that's fine you guys
want to talk about fun stuff
sorry all i have is a new hannah gatsby
documentary a
stand-up trailer that's what we're going
to play
so uh for those who don't know this is
nanette right this is the uh
the one who uh what was the thing she
had wiped from a wikipedia mic
i was right she said she was
walking around all sexy like yeah
looking here i was walking around with
me jugs hanging out looking all
appetizing and i got
and then i came to america became famous
for mariah
but then i went back and had me with me
wikipedia scrub day
and oddly enough it was right around the
time that jesse small it was going
through his health thing
he wasn't he was he was allegedly beaten
by some nigerians but me
always was so i say so then i had it
scrubbed i did
because i was i got famous for being
let's check it out
i had no plans to make it in america
that should that should have been the
end of it that should have been the end
of the trailer right there we move on
if you're here because of nanette
looking good
i came here with two beard knees freshly
in a dream do you have a mediocre
netflix special
why
had i known just how wildly popular
trauma was going to be
in the context of comedy i might have
budgeted my [ __ ] a bit better
the emmy and peabody award-winning
special in that
no not by the way none of those things
are uh are
comedy based so
i went and put all my drama eggs into
one basket like a [ __ ] idiot and now
here we are
gatsby continues to redefine the
stand-up comedy form
it's just not good though that means
we're see comedy used to mean
people going on stage and being funny
and
and this makes me and now and now she's
redefining that
i'll tell you what i'm happy about see
comedies now when you go on stage and
you talk about being
and you make everyone see it and you get
a lot of clapping
what is it called um
something pause it's like some kind of
uh laugh clause or whatever it is it's
like the polite clapping that you get at
all these uh
comedy shows now that's what they're
going for uh you know that somebody said
in the chat just remember royce has seen
this wait for his laughing i for his
acting i've never i haven't seen this
trailer mike sent this to me one minute
before the show
that's the other one the other
conspiracy that it's one of my favorite
ones too is that
i pre-watch all the videos yeah and and
then i act
when i see them when i first started
touring here i was told i should
americanize my language to which i
responded torres sponted
i don't know if you know this you're not
but i was
and it gives me a pass to do whatever i
want
oh i was you know
don't check me wikipedia because you
won't see it referenced on there anymore
because a lot of people say that maybe
there was no police
report ever filed in me so that maybe
technically or on paper never really
happened
and that maybe it just kind of came to
america and seen it
just so i could school walk points
this is um i'll tell you me watching
this trailer it makes me happy that
there's no comedy going on right now
because
well no this is comedy rice no but i
mean my point is is that you know people
like this don't get to do it
well that's a good freeze frame but that
jesus christ christ that's what it
looked like when she was fake
is there a bad freeze frame for for a
good one again
see here yeah [ __ ] off and all i see
is the world needs in 2020
a an australian version of uh
paula pantstown i mean i i've made some
concessions for you i'm not a monster
hannah gadsby i came to america to
answer the question
what if paula poundstone was the one who
was
you you do look like a monster aluminum
why would you say aluminium when you can
flirt it
why are you why are you look like a bob
kelly
[Laughter]
you know what dude you know it's like
boom
get a special i broke my hymen dude
[Laughter]
aluminum stop it america
stop it turmeric shut up and y'all
i'm taking y'all i love y'all because
y'all
is the best most inclusive
second person plural pronoun in the
english speaking world yeah
pronoun jokes
sorry i'm acting i've already seen this
pronoun
jokes
it's really funny guys i would trade
hannah gatsby
for demi lodner and a heartbeat
really yeah i could see that
in a heartbeat because at least demi
lodner's
yeah you know i mean it's a certain
charm to
just being able to laugh at her
[Applause]
thank you the south what an ally
i don't know if you know this royce
but she was
woke comedy
is okay i have another sorry i just saw
something
how do you get a camel toe in slacks
how do you get a camel toe in slacks
honestly if you go like this
and you take the upper body and the face
out
i would swear i was looking at a picture
of ralphie may from the waist down
yeah your dress is is it the shoes
clapter claptor thank you
uh i love cool nice
and i think we need to respect that i
don't think she was in new zealand royce
the same place that the christ happened
coincidence no because one of those two
things didn't actually happen we're not
going to say which one because we want
to keep our channel
look guys grow up
okay mike going for the claptor today
huh grow up
that's very serious
matters well one of them are
[Applause]
yes i can't wait finally something to
watch during this [ __ ] lockdown huh
something good to watch in this lockdown
i don't know if you know this royce
but hannah gatsby is the world's number
one
being female comic
is there other ones oh well her and uh
uh cameron
carmen esposito or cameron esposito i
think they're they're battling the guy
who played gus fring
no that's it's a different guy that's
giancarlo esposito all right well look i
don't know